by our foxnews count the house is now
just five GOP votes away from bringing
several daca bills to the House floor
via something called a discharge
petition it's basically a parliamentary
tactic to get around the GOP leadership
that we told you about last night
so-called moderate Republicans and
Democrats are working together to
advance a bill that would give amnesty
to dreamers that's our ultimate goal
speaker Paul Ryan calls the effort
pointless because the president would
veto it let's get the inside story from
House Majority Whip Steve Scalise
congressman Scalise this is really
upsetting to a lot of us who have seen
how this movie always ends in 2007 the
amnesty thing went down in flames
2013/14 it was so bad with a gang of
eight that even Marco Rubio now he's
like stepped back from that and now here
we are in the midterm elections we need
everybody unified and these frankly open
borders Republicans that's what I call
them are pushing this move what's
happening well Laura first of all it's
good to be back with you and I don't
want to see this discharge petition move
because I want to solve the problem I'm
a co-sponsor of the Goodlatte McCall
bill which really does address all of
the different pillars and migration and
all the other issues on the wall secure
the border and chain migration the Visa
Lottery and address daca which was a
problem by the way that Barack Obama
created he said hey come to this country
illegally bring your kids and it's still
illegal we're not gonna try to change
the law we'll just look the other way
and let somebody else fix it President
Trump said he actually wants to solve
this problem and we're working with
President Trump to get a solution but
blanket amnesty with no border
protection and no wall is not the answer
what's happening behind closed doors you
guys had a big meeting yesterday and it
got pretty heated what's the feeling is
this a big divide in the party is this
20 25 Republican you know immigrations
always been a complicated issue within
the Republican Conference because you
can see the different approaches that we
wanted to what did the president run on
he ran on law and order at the borders
secure not this nonsense will the wall
and Congress passes an omnibus bill that
doesn't fund the wall the president I
think was led to believe it did that's
what Republicans are really there's not
a 110 miles of new wall in the omnibus
but ultimately we want
what we want is a long-term solution the
full funding for the wall but really the
other issues are so important to and
that is interior enforcement look
secretary Neilson will tell you right
now this catch-and-release these other
programs where she literally can have a
felon come out of prison who's here
illegally and she can't deport him out
of the country we need to close those
loopholes we need to end a lot of those
problems friends of mine like martha
mcsalley have worked really hard on
those provisions of Goodlatte McCall to
make sure that we can get back to rule
of law and secure our border and so
that's the approach we would like to
take work and what President Trump who
wants to solve the problem this is what
Nancy Pelosi said today about this let's
watch bring up the bill bring up all
their bills queen of the hill we believe
that this bipartisan bill that the
members have put together who share the
value of protecting the dreamers is the
bill that would win we have an answer
there is a path let's get it done and if
not why not everyone watching should
know that the 20 Republicans who are
pushing this discharge visit petition
are with the person you just saw on the
screen Nancy Pelosi yeah that is
shocking we now have 40 percent of
Americans congressman Scalise who say
that country's going in the right
direction it was about 30% of that
numbers growing withdrawing and growing
because of what president Trump's been
doing to get the economy moving again
get regulations under control work with
us on so many issues like that that are
that are really the most meaningful for
people and then you look at Nancy Pelosi
just last week she said if she was
Speaker again she would raise your taxes
she would try to undo these great Trump
tax cuts that we were able to get
through but keep in mind when Nancy
Pelosi was speaker the entire time she
had the majority she never tried to fix
this problem was until they lost the
majority that all of a sudden she wanted
to do something so they had super
majorities they never tried to solve
daca they wanted as a political issue we
want to solve the problem but in a way
that restores rule of law and builds the
wall now you and McCarthy have been
holding the line on this tough tough
stance that tough said it make you're
reflecting the will of the people and
reflecting the President's agenda which
is for me the only path forward for the
GOP at this point Jeff Denham big
liberal Republican I'm sorry I'm sure
he's a friend ears but he was on Martha
I think with martha maccallum show her
tucker show tonight excuse me
he basically said this is the way to
deliver a solution to the president the
president wants a solution this is the
answer he said there are a lot of bills
who get are possible but we're
delivering a comprehensive solution that
will stop the five hundred thousand
people a year whatever it is crossing
the border yeah look Jeff's a friend but
we disagree strongly on this and and I
think that's the wrong approach that
he's taken but ultimately we want to do
is work with President Trump to find a
solution proposing some idea that's
gonna bring the DREAM Act to the House
floor and maybe even pass something like
the DREAM Act which is blanket amnesty
for more than three million people with
no border security that's not only not
the right answer
but president Trump would even veto that
bill so why pursue some agenda that why
are they veto why are they do I don't we
continue working together to try to get
a solution to president Trump would sign
into law to solve the problem beerus the
president no I think that they you know
look and they come from districts where
they want to do something different than
that we want if you want it let's get
the right solution that president Trump
will sign so you're too nice the New
Orleanians or the Louisianans are too
nice okay I'm from Connecticut we'll
just say no this guy we have some street
brawl and - but at the end of the day we
want to get this problem solved great to
see is always right come back soon